so I have another keto meal evaluation
for you this is by someone named ViSalus
or bacillus I'm not sure which will how
do you pronounce it okay so this is all
the data that I have I don't have
anything more than that okay Kiwi sheep
yogurt five almonds and I would imagine
this is the snack before lunch I'm not
sure maybe this is breakfast I don't
know I have to get more data on that and
then we have beet leaves eggs tomato and
from the picture it looks like there's
two eggs they're boiled chard and cow's
milk okay so that's the data that I have
there's some shooting electrical pain on
the right side the body I'm not sure
exactly where if it's in the upper part
of the body it's gonna be gallbladder if
it's in a lower part of the body or even
the midsection it could potentially be
gall bladder or kidney so I'm not sure
you did lose weight 131 kilograms down
to 116 kilograms so obviously it's
working you drink four to five liters of
water per day okay there is some
problems with digestion so I'm thinking
gallbladder okay needs exercise
okay so let's just kind of look at this
well as a couple things right off the
bat that I would change I would
eliminate the fruit Kiwi I would
eliminate the yogurt because yogurt does
have too much sugar I would take these
almonds and push them to the meal so we
we don't have multiple meals that's
gonna actually greatly improve digestion
right there I actually like what you're
eating I like the tomatoes beet leaves
the boiled chard I mean it'd be nice to
have like a raw salad added on to that
but you're still getting some fiber here
depending on how cooked the vegetables
are for the microbes to consume you're
still getting some nutrition I would
imagine especially if there's a beet
leaves there this is like massive
amounts of potassium right here I think
it's like 100 and I guess that's
basically 1300 milligrams of potassium
per cup so that's awesome
so that will help you but I think you
need a little bit more which then will
also help the digestion too as far as
the gallbladder area if there is a
gallbladder issue there cow's milk I'm
not crazy about that so maybe do almond
milk that might be better because this
is pasteurized and there's just a lot of
issues with cow's milk okay
so this right here could be kidney your
gall bladder like I said what you could
do is once you have this pain massage
underneath the right ribcage about a
inch down and inch off the midline and
press in there for a minute or so and
see if that pain goes away if it's your
gall bladder it'll go away like that and
then we know we might need to add some
support with your digestion so maybe
some batain how to chloride or even a
bile salts called that a formula or
something but it could be the kidney
because if you're doing I don't know one
and a half meals a day
your uric acid can go up with certain
people that are prone to that especially
when you're adapting initially and you
could even develop little crystals
inside the kidney or even a stone a uric
acid stone okay so when you do in a
minute fasting in the transition phase
it could increase the absolute best
remedy to counter that is called
hydroxycitric hydroxy citric you can get
that online and start taking that that
dissolves crystals both oxide stones and
uric acid stones also you can use
potassium citrate too but this hydroxy
Scituate works a little bit better you
might want to also add lemon water which
by the way will alkalize your body even
though it's a citrate fYI need to
exercise I think that's that's good
there with this much liquid okay I would
also add some electrolytes to the mix
alright so those are my suggestions go
ahead and do it and let me know how you
do
so if you haven't done so please press
subscribe now that way you can be aware
of all the new content that I'm putting
out on a regular basis